y las respuestas serán acordes a la
gravedad y envergadura de los crímenes
esa es la pregunta que se hacen las
víctimas mientras los obispos franceses
se preparan para decidir qué medidas
tomarán tras el informe del mes pasado
sobre los abusos de la iglesia católica
francesa tras reunirse a puerta cerrada
los 120 miembros de la conferencia
episcopal de francia votarán una serie
de propuestas que incluyen indemnizar a
las víctimas introducir cambios en la
formación del clero o aumentar la
supervisión las víctimas esperan que la
iglesia convierta finalmente sus
palabras en acciones concretas
han reconocido la responsabilidad de la
institución lo que ya es un paso
importante pero hay que dar otro paso
compensar a las víctimas y quizás
modernizarse un poco a nivel estructural
las cosas tienen que cambiar eso es
evidente
se esperan dos grandes reformas la
creación de un organismo nacional
independiente que reconozca a las
víctimas como tales y se encargue de sus
demandas y la creación de un fondo que
financie esta estructura
para indemnizar a las víctimas muchos
esperan que los anuncios del lunes
incluyan también detalles sobre la
creación de un tribunal penal
eclesiástico que juzgue a los sacerdotes
y obispos acusados de abusos en octubre
un extenso informe independiente reveló
que hasta 300.000 niños sufrieron abusos
sexuales en el seno de la iglesia
católica francesa durante las últimas
siete décadas algo que la iglesia ignoró
deliberadamente